québec vient en aide au cirque du soleil
dont les activités sont paralysées
depuis le début de la pandémie
le conseil des ministres a autorisé une
aide financière pouvant atteindre 200
millions de dollars américains 275
millions canadiens
l'accord a été conclu entre les
investisseurs actuels du cirque et
investissement québec québec devient un
créancier du cirque obtient une option
de rachat des actions de type i jy et
fosun si ses actionnaires décident de se
retirer
le siège social du cirque du soleil doit
rester au québec
les hauts dirigeants doivent résider au
québec leur rémunération doit être
raisonnable également pierre fait qui
est bonne et le ministre de l'économie
de l'innovation du québec
bonsoir monsieur fatigue est bonne
bonjour j'ai vu lyon aide financière
vous devenez créanciers mais pas
actionnaire pas de prise de
participation à proprement parler
pourquoi vous procédez ainsi âprement
faut comprendre que nous voulions ancrer
la violence cette soleil sur des
fondations solides qui vais croiser dans
les actionnaires existants le groupe de
fosun dpg la caisse des dépôts nous ont
demandés un support financier pour
investir dans le site soleil et on avait
des conditions comme créancier pour
pouvoir les aider et on aura une clause
de rachat aucun comme avait dit quand
tpg vossen goudron bang ou dantin on
pourrait forcer le rachat d actions par
le gouvernement sur une base il demande
à voir parce que c'est pas les tensions
d'une robe nude expertise j'ai eu du
soleil
mais pourquoi pas actionnaire maintenant
un moment où le cirque du soleil doit
faire des choix prendre des décisions se
trouver un investisseur un acquéreur
pourquoi vous prenez pas le volant les
deux mains sur le volant pour reprendre
une vieille expression
je pense qu'il faut reconnaître qu'il
est le meilleur du gouvernement il faut
comprendre aussi que notre support va
être en baisse donc retoqué ans ce qui
est relativement seniors g1 mêmes
garanties
vous avez là aussi gai là je pense que
c'est plus prudent projet l'argent des
citoyens québécois et cet argent là va
être disponible au cirque si le code de
tpg le groupe d'actionnaires
deviez le nouveau propriétaire parce
qu'on comprend qu'un concours il ya un
processus s'est pas encore automatique
le scénar existants vont pouvoir
continuer dans notre aide financière qui
est très bien structuré va seulement
exécutoire si le groupe existant
continue et c'est pas le rôle du
gouvernement des fonctionnaires
doit-on ouvert aussi donc si un autre
groupe qui se présente il ya des
acheteurs du cirque n'est pas dit que
vous allez mettre 200 millions que vous
allez avoir besoin de lui même
exactement j'ai toujours dit que le
gouvernement ne peut pas à mettre de
l'argent dans ses courses en premier
dans le cas présent dans le plan
d'affaires qui était proposé un tissu de
capital qui est à notre avis
conservatrices donc pas beaucoup de
dettes parce qu'on s'entend que le
ceinturait vous l'avez dit aurait été
contre le dans ces opérations
on va reprendre la vie ou s'il sera
prendre quelques années donc c'est par
une source du capital très conservatrice
ce qu'on ne lui présente pas il on va
voir ce qui va arriver que les autres
repreneurs vos certains son public sur
la rétention en othe notre support va se
mettre en place si le groupe actuel de
vielles de m'approprier tadjik skip
accord assure yvon plus donc si guy
laliberté achète le cirque aussi pierre
karl péladeau quebecor achète le cercle
est ce que vous allez être là où il n'y
a plus de soutien financier à ce moment
là non le soutien financier que nous
avons accordé est basée sur des
conditions financières et non
financières
alors si quelqu'un qui devient poveda du
cirque parce qu'il y aura fait rire plus
aux clients ainsi que le groupe existe
un et qu'il respecte les conditions que
nous avons établies langage québécois
et s'ils ont besoin de nous on se doit
est ce que votre soutien aujourd'hui
vient sauver le cirque du soleil
généreux jusqu'à sauver mais même moment
je jasais haut niveau en cage
nous avons établi les paramètres que
nous jugeons important et pour moi de
toucher à la politique
j'ai réalisé l'importance c'est du
soleil pour le côté créatif au québec
note écosystèmes je veux nous voulons
que le cndd soleil de mer au québec que
c'est le soleil herpen sur des bases
solides sur l'objectif principal ce
qu'on a fait aujourd'hui avec les
actionnaires existants
c'est qu'on établit
la fondation sur laquelle nous pensons
que le cycle peuvent redevenir ce qu'il
était c'est en dix ans nous sommes pas
en contrôle de la situation vous savez
très bien que ce sont les créanciers du
site sont eux qui vont décider avec qui
veut faire affaire alors nous on aime on
a choisi de travailler avec tpg parce
que le son est clair existants le seco
publiées quand même avant le cobp il y
avait trop de dettes avait opéré bien
mais on est capable et flexible aussi si
un autre acheteur paient plus cher que
le cycle que le goût d'actionnaires
existants ou des meilleures conditions
la semaine on pourra voir si on doit
être fier on ne doit pas terrifier mais
on va être là si ça peut aider
beaucoup de gens qui ont de la
difficulté à comprendre pourquoi type i
jy cap et aux très riches milliards des
milliards d'investissements la caisse
défaut très riche bien sûr la caisse de
dépôt force on également
pourquoi le gouvernement doit intervenir
auprès d'investisseurs aussi profitable
et aussi riche pas du tout surpris mais
quand vous êtes en coton cote la
naturalisation soit public parce qu'un
jour on voit que tpg par ce qu'ils vont
faire
je veux dire que les actionnaires
existants remettre de l'argent
aussi faut comprendre que beaucoup
d'argent qui va être acquis pour
repartir le site compare ou appart
derniers mois je pense qu'on parle d'eux
peut-être deux à trois ans avant de
revenir à la profitabilité qu'ils
avaient avant le trio kobe deuxièmement
faut comprendre aussi que le rôle de
créancier principal via l'ancien c'est
en quelque sorte c'est pas d'autres
dettes
cette position privilégiée je pense que
80 je regarde la gestion des fonds
publics
je pense une bonne occasion d'avoir un
retour sur investissement intéressants
et de laisser les actionnaires à
d'autres actionnaires de soin de gérer
les gérer le site donc la position nous
allons prendre dans le sens si tpg
réussi à continuer comme actionnaire
seule pulsion qui est relativement
privilégiés constant je cite ça vaut
plus de l'argent qu'on met il ya
beaucoup d'entreprises qui tombent au
combat en ce moment parce qu'on a fermé
l'économie parce que la réouverture est
graduelle par ce qui est des secteurs
qui demeurent fermés les entreprises qui
se place sous la protection qui font
faillite qui ne peuvent pas reprendre
leurs activités
allez-vous les aider aussi ces
entreprises
pourquoi aider le cirque et pas toutes
les entreprises qui sont en difficulté
financière
on va m'aider plusieurs vous rappeler
que le programme que nous avons annoncé
le pacte ps étaient eux et les
programmes et pirelli
on a présentement peu près 1.1.8
milliard de demandes d'assistance et je
pensais l'euro du gouvernement pour les
grandes sociétés
les grands donneurs d'ordre qui ont un
impact important sur les échos indiquent
ses hôtes vraiment je pense de mettre la
charge des batteries permettent que les
entreprises survivent
alors le succès pour la seule qu'on va
aider est-ce qu'on est d'une entreprise
en aidant le cirque du soleil qui avait
déjà des problèmes financiers et qui a
pris des mauvaises décisions au cours
des dernières années
bonne que si on veut faire attention
quand on regarde le cirque du soleil est
intéressant de noter que la
profitabilité du cirque du soleil avait
un intérêt appelle le bélier de famille
avec le concept le bailleur du cirque
étaient supérieurs avant de crever qu'il
était à 2015 qu'elles aient été achetés
donc la performance du management sur
celle du soleil est une bonne
performance qui après avoir le plus
grande profitabilité peut-être mais sont
plus profitables aujourd'hui qu'il
l'était avant la crise
la problématique du cirque du soleil
était le niveau d'endettement je
comprends que les fonds d'équité
arriviez canadiens aiment de
l'adaptation mais de la dette plus de
retour sur l'équité et puissant alors
c'est ça qui était la première sur une
façon de mener deux éléments comme tpg
capital est exactement la raison pour
laquelle nous avons dit nous sommes
prêts à être prêté à mettre aux
conditions historiques des conditions
qui vont en corrélation avec
l'environnement n'a qu'un mot vivre le
cycle aura d'être soudés par 3 1 donc je
pense que c'était la raison pour que le
site a été soulevée cette situation
c'est très mal géré et de beaucoup trop
tête
merci beaucoup monsieur fait keven
plaisir